so thank you for coming to my talk I
have to say I was a little bit concerned
about security that I've just been sort
of wandering around with an unidentified
person eating for free
sort of gobbling up resources with no
badge but it just shows how friendly
everyone here is so my name is Ellie
Nielsen I am a software engineer and
sort of jack-of-all-trades at one drop
in new york city we are a super lean
super small diabetes management platform
and our goal is to sort of revolutionize
the idea of the quantified the
quantified self in treating chronic
illnesses like diabetes so I'm happy to
talk to people about that but not during
the talk okay
so the title of my talk is no sequel
Python why other than the trend of your
name right no sequel is a buzz word you
are probably coming with this with all
sorts of expectations that are gonna not
be fulfilled but I kind of wanted to
grab your attention and present sort of
my version of why I care about no sequel
so first I'll be telling you why I
picked that title and why this matters
to me secondly a little bit of how just
sort of nuts and bolts this is actually
I'll warn you now in case you want to
head out it's sort of the Nitty Gritty
of dealing with nasty file formats and
things like this when we're not using
nice clean sequel data and then finally
going back to the why again hopefully
now a sort of more compelling
data-driven way rather than my just
editorial editorializing so the why
let's start with standard sequel like
tidy data how many people know this
buzzword tidy this is very popular in
the art community but I think it's also
making its way over to the Python
community and for good reason
so what makes this data tidy there's a
few things first the observations are in
or in rows every individual observation
gets its own row we don't do any sort of
polluting one row with another we don't
want to have many many columns that's
part of the idea of Tidy only your
variables are in columns right something
that can be different and it's contained
in a single data set and I think we all
like that right
on all our data in one place readily
accessible can you tell me anything
useful about this data stack quick quick
quick what do you see okay not fast
enough I will I'll go tip you off a bit
and say maybe if you look here you'll
see something useful what useful info
did I have okay what's the high score 25
what's the low score how many people oh
there's a big delay right how many days
big delay right let's switch it up so
these things are easy to see the high
score the low score the total
observations that one is sort of easy to
see right that's never going to be that
easy
not so easy though are things like how
many people who's doing the best once
you realize there's repeats right who's
doing the worst and how is a particular
individual doing right so let's say I'm
a grade school teacher these are some of
my students and some of their scores I'm
if I'm storing my data this way that's
not fantastic right I don't have some
sort of easy to access easy to think
about way of categorizing how my
students are doing okay I'm gonna change
it up a bit I'm looking for a better
format what changed my sorting right so
now I'm sorting by day instead of by
score so what do I get now that's better
well at least one thing right how many
days that that becomes clearer so I in
case I forgot because I've been so busy
changing the world and changing these
students Minds I actually now remember
how many days I gave tests on but
there's still a lot of things I can't
see that I would say I can see really
well when I do this so this data is not
tidy right so there might be people who
are really mad right now if you're
really mad right now you're probably not
going to like most of what I do during
this talk and I've gotten yelled at by
lots of people you don't do this this is
terrible this is dirty dirty data I
don't like it but I can eyeball it
really easily right like this is sort of
how I want to be thinking about my
students how's Joe doing well he went
from a 1 to a 14 to a 17
stick so new questions become
interesting and easier to answer before
what you could tell me quickly was maybe
the highest score in the lowest score
well that's sort of interesting but it's
not terribly interesting when I want to
know say how my child is doing if I'm
talking to the teacher new questions
become interesting and easier to answer
I think is the most important because
what I sometimes worry about is that the
way we're storing our data is actually
sort of affecting the questions we're
asking and the questions we're willing
to answer right and I think especially
the ladder we've probably all had this
experience I have this experience every
week especially in a small start-up
where I am like the only person who
touches the database anything that's not
sort of easy to answer yes it's an
interesting question but I can sort of
feel myself being like yeah yeah I'll
get to that but that one's complicated
and then if they ask me something that's
really easy based on my format I'm like
boom and I send that to you in five
minutes and so to some extent the
company I'm working for is deeply deeply
influenced by how I've chosen to store
my data and I'm sure it's the same
wherever you are working that if it's
easy to do and joyful to do you do it
quickly and otherwise not so much so
some of the questions that now become
easy to answer how many students are
there who improved who improved Joe
improved who missed a test
Alan missed a test he was kind of mad
Mary's kind of married she's sort of
fussing around no clear trend okay so
don't get mad I'm not saying to kill the
idea of tidy data but I worry that we
don't use certain methods or ask certain
questions more often just because it's
not as easy as it could be given
whatever data storage we've decided on
and here are some examples that in my
experience and colleagues experiences
are not that easy to answer when you're
working with a tidy mindset or a very
strongly sequal mindset in app analytics
or game analytics what usage patterns do
we see in a long term user right so I
want to backtrack
look at a particular user and see what
he did each day how do those patterns
evolve over time at the individual level
right so not how is the whole community
using my app but how is this individual
using my app now versus how this
individual used my app a couple weeks
ago or even a couple days
health research can we predict earlier
on an experiment what's likely to happen
right
sometimes people continue experiments
for a long time but you kind of wonder
if they actually could have backtracked
and figured out much earlier on oh you
know you don't need that plus the above
anymore let's switch you over and
empirically we know that that's only
done when the results are really really
strong but people are usually just
looking at the overall success number
they're not sort of looking at
trajectories right so we have to wonder
if these are being done as efficiently
as they can I would argue in part
because they're using these sort of
sequel like thinking and sequel like
data storage formats where I'm really
just looking at that final number so I'm
trying to move us to thinking about
something more than who had the highest
score who had the lowest score similarly
consumer research if you don't know you
probably haven't worked in consumer
research but people like different
things purely depending on the order
they see them in you might show me a
dress and if it's the first thing I see
I'm like oh that's a crap dress like I
don't want that dress if it's the fourth
thing you show me I might fall in love
with it I mean that's just sort of how
malleable the human brain is so if
you're working in any sort of field
that's related to telling people what
they like or figuring out what people
like you to should be paying more
attention to the things ordering happens
in ok so I'm probably hammering this
home way too hard but I also even wanted
to do a little bit of psychology about
why this is so important and why I know
I tended not to ask no sequel questions
all that often before even though I had
the data to answer them and even though
they are interesting if you're not the
one who has to do the work
one is status quo bias humans tend to
take whatever default is presented right
that happens in data analysis too so
when I give you that first graph right
that shows the tests in order when I
asked you what's interesting or what you
know you're gonna go to that ordered
column right because that's really the
easy place to know something and down an
effect humans tend to want what they
already have and think it's more
valuable than what's offered for a trade
so have you ever had sort of the new guy
or a girl join your engineering team and
say oh you guys use post grads well
that's interesting but you know we were
using mom
and it's awesome and you're sort of like
I like what I've got I like my database
like it must be better because it's the
one I have already right so we've all
sort of gone through this or you join a
new team but you're still attached to
your old set up your old stack and you
have that same bias and then this one
this is a really deep one and you guys
are gonna be surprised but this is a you
know personal field research especially
dude finding humans are lazy in general
right and we are no exception
we don't want to do work that's hard
work so this is all about like let's
just store an array in a data field
rather than you know tidy data that's my
initial argument and you would say well
you know that's not really no sequel
that's just straight-up pandas or data
frames in our or in Python and you know
you can always sort of reconstruct these
trajectories and I'm sure you guys who
went to the pandas tutorial this morning
have many better ideas but you know when
I sort of off the cuff the top of my
head think how am I gonna do this well
one way I think is okay I'm gonna do a
group by and then I'm gonna apply some
kind of lambda function and I'm gonna
sort by the day and then I'm gonna grab
the score for each person that's okay I
did it I don't think this passes muster
under Pat eighty I think that's a really
long ugly line and not that easy to
think about but I also don't even get
all the data I want right what's
something that's missing yeah right I
don't actually have a day it might be in
the right order but knowing Alan had
only two doesn't tell me which one he
missed kind of important okay the night
then I thought of another one and again
I am NOT claiming to be a panda Swizz
but I just thought okay well then I'm
gonna just make a new list I'm gonna go
through that tuple that comes out of the
group I and for each of those I'm gonna
sort of make a little mini dictionary
and stick that on my list oh now we're
all super happy right that I mean this
is the opposite of tidy right I've got a
list with a dictionary inside this is
okay I mean at least I know sort of when
Alan missed his test now I don't know
that this is especially easy to read
right I mean which field was the day
versus which was the score not easy not
easy is really important I think that's
something I want you to take away from
today just because you can no it doesn't
mean you know it easily right and
anything you don't know easily becomes
increasingly remote right the harder it
is to know the less you really know it
even though it's accessible another one
well why don't I just you know to make
it neither I'm gonna define a function
and then this function I'm gonna sort of
do some kind of row selection list
comprehension type thing because I like
really long list comprehensions and then
I'm gonna have a nice little apply well
that sort of gets me what I want but I
mean this is not really what Python is
supposed to look like right we want our
Python to be nice and short and
expressive and beautiful and I wouldn't
say this is and not that it always has
to be but I'm not thrilled with this so
my argument is don't stir it this way
and that's part of why I want to spend
the next portion of the talk saying well
why don't we just store it in originally
in this format right why didn't I just
write down these arrays to begin with so
I don't have to be going through these
hoops with my pandas okay but a little
bit more on the wire right let's be
honest no one wants to be that any of
those processes I've just suggested and
there's obviously others like rien
dexing I'm sure people in the audience
have better ideas but you don't want
that to be a first step to every query
you're going to make right increasingly
we're going to be making these sorts of
queries not about who had the highest
test score who had the lowest test score
but rather about how things happen right
it wasn't that that wasn't important in
the past but we have more and more data
where we know how things happen right
Google Ads I feel a little less
surveilled in Europe than I do back home
in the States but I think nonetheless
that Google is following me around they
definitely know I'm in Amsterdam you
know it's almost like I get here and
they're like welcome Aileen we haven't
seen you in eight hours while you're on
the plane
so lots and lots of time series data
wearable sensors this is actually
something my company is working on to do
with diabetes but this is I mean this is
coming people have sports clothing with
little sensors you're just gonna be
tracked all the time with everything
which means everything is a time series
right everything you do every data point
you provide or you get as an analyst is
gonna have a time stamp and it's a
meaningful time stamp right now it's not
just one the data entry
got to it so the unit of observation
should be the actor not the particular
action observed at a particular time I
think we need to move away from this
tidy idea that what I saw at a
particular moment with the person just
being a variable is the way to go and be
thinking more and acknowledging more
that everything is happening in some
kind of time oriented context so we
should be rethinking what we mean by
observations okay I also want to point
out we don't look for no sequel because
we have no sequel databases right so I
don't think this is a case of the intern
just found out how mungo works and they
think it's awesome and they want to like
try out this new sequence so they're
like trying to cram things in right the
point is is all coming because our
infrastructure is evolving what we can
know is evolving it's becoming more
contextual and so for that reason the
data is gonna be more no sequel like so
I'm not going to go through this list I
guess the ones I would highlight though
are that the schema will be changing all
the time right people are constantly
tacking on new things as they realize
they can measure them if you have more
of a sequel mindset you're going to
think oh no that's another table that's
another joint I need to write that's
like you know more group by statements I
need to worry about
similarly the patterns are gonna change
all the time right you stop recording
something you record it in a new way you
define the events in a new way this is
definitely happening where I work where
we're constantly rewriting our app in
response to how users are responding to
it right so anyone who's working in a in
a company that does a lot of a/b testing
you know things are constantly changing
right your intro sequence is changing
everything you do is changing okay
so what is no sequel Python for me I
would say it's one you have to deal with
sort of arbitrarily nested data this is
something you see with no sequel right I
can collect at any data point as much as
I want to know right so maybe when
you're wearing your sensor first and
just like well where was Joe at 2
o'clock and where was he at 3 o'clock
but then my sensor gets smarter and now
I'm like well what was Joe's heart rate
or what was Joe wearing or you know what
was Joe thinking what was his mood right
and I started adding feels and you know
I started with an array of one value and
soon I have
dictionaries and soon I have an array
with them an array and all that ragged
data similarly like that I sort of take
it or I don't take it it can be a length
of one or a zero or 1,500 I just have no
idea but I want to be able to compare
against individuals even if I have
different amounts of information about
them and that is related to comparative
time series same idea okay so where do
we find no sequel data here's where I
have found it and this is why it's been
on my mind I found it anywhere from a
physics lab to working on a running app
to now I work with health data that sort
of comes in when it feels like and
sometimes it stops coming in and how do
we make sense of that write or read it
as a popular example for people who read
reddit that is highly highly nested data
but it's also all the time series right
everything is coming in with a timestamp
and in response to things I came in
earlier okay so on to the how definitely
the most boring part of the talk if you
want to go to sleep this is the time
getting the data into Python when it's
straightforward this is a scenario
you're grabbing a bunch of no sequel
data from an API or from a no sequel DB
I'm mostly thinking about JSON it's a
common format please
especially for textual data best-case
scenario you sort of take well
everything you can get in this case I
would stick with pandas and I just want
to point out that normalized JSON works
really well raise your hand if you've
worked with normalize JSON oh man so you
guys are all just have like data
engineers to do everything for you I see
how it is I just want you to know if you
ever don't have a data engineer to parse
stuff for you and you think you're
looking at something that's way too
complicated I just want to give you the
good news that actually normalized JSON
is like amazing it will take care of
almost everything as long as you want
everything there is and as long as the
format isn't too perverse so if you look
at this for example I've got a Jane Doe
and a Bob Smith first thing I'll point
out is I've sort of got random fields
right so one thing has a field the other
one doesn't
another problem I don't just have random
fields that are in one record but not
the other
some of
my raise oh well that's wonderful I also
this one is especially egregious I have
the same field series one is an array of
dictionaries the other one's just a
dictionary oh well this I mean we all
love coding for situations like this
right actually you don't have to if you
just sort of chug this in with the
normal JSON normalized it comes out
really well it will say oh yeah that's a
dictionary no problem or that's an array
of dictionaries no problem that's what
your data field is going to be in that
column so you can mix and match it just
takes care of it and it's also easy to
add columns so for example I use the
apply on length that works both on the
individual and on the array so basic
lesson is things have gotten developed
enough know JSON as long as it's correct
is all that awful and you're gonna get
really nice really nice columns and
everything so basically there's no
excuse not to deal with this um there
are some things you can do right using
some programmer stuff I'm more on the
software side than the data side so this
is interesting to me one thing is you
can subclass an iterable to shorten your
apply calls raise your hand if that
sentence makes no sense to you okay so
that's fair enough I know lots of people
are much more on the data end
so this basically means like if you use
the normal list that's fine but you
can't customize I want to list but I
kind of want to list at those special
things and in particular let's say I
know I have a list but I don't want to
have to like write out apply and a
function to write the average so instead
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna define or
subclass under call this is one of these
functions that will come with any object
it basically just means if you take a
class member and you put parens after it
you get this function right so I can
sort of make myself a special list it's
a subclass of the Python list and it
will behave as I want right so if I just
want every time I put parens after my
instance to get the average I can do
something like that if you want to do
this there's like ton you can do with
this this is one of the reasons I think
Python is just so well-suited to the
sort of data processing I will plan out
you
- at least subclass yet item and it er
those two you should probably subclass
in it as well in cases of inconsistent
format so if you remember the JSON we
just looked at in one field I had both
under I and a dictionary right if I'm
gonna subclass that I'm sort of assuming
I'm gonna get a list but I should
probably check that I've got that list
right so there are a couple of gotchas
but make the fact that classes are first
class instances in Python and are very
dynamically assignable work for you it's
actually one of the reasons Python is so
great for data management then for
example what I do I don't know if this
is best practice but it's super flexible
call can be a catch-all adjustable
function right so sort of anything I
want to happen to that data that's in my
column that has now been subclassed
saves my DF list I can keep rewriting
call to do whatever I want and then
instead of those really long Python
lines you know telling telling the apply
function what to do I just put those
parens afterwards and boom it's nice
it's short and it's beautiful um I'll
also point out that custom classes pair
nicely with class methods right so
especially when you want to be able to
swap flop swap things out as you're
going right so first I want my call to
be one thing first I wanted to compute
the me and then I wanted to just print
out the name whatever it is it's very
easy if you make it a class method to
just swap things in and out right so
here you can see I did that I took tests
and I actually assigned a new function
to it so if you do a lot of sort of
console level data exploration you
already have a whole column subclass to
some class that you fully control you
can swap out those Clapp about this and
again it just makes your life really
easy okay so getting no sequel data
commonly encountered problems this stuff
is not thrilling and I am going a lot
slower than I thought I would so I'm
gonna speed through this raise your hand
if you have any particular questions
weird CSV files this tends to be things
where you get an array in a CSV or some
JSON this is pretty straightforward
usually you're just gonna use reg X and
common Python string operations to clean
up the data reg X is never fun except
for people who do it every day Stack
Overflow is a great read
earth tried a few times and you usually
figure out what you want apply is your
best friend and then a couple of common
problems are things like just having a
space where you shouldn't
so really SP has about 20 parameters I
can promise you whatever problem you are
encountering one of those parameters
takes care of it so just like JSON
normalizes amazing
so is read CSV so for example if you
have a CSV it's gonna look like this and
in particular you'll see the way we put
the arrays in we actually just put them
in quotation marks this doesn't work
great because it's a string but actually
you just need I wouldn't even call this
reg X just very normal Python processing
to split this into an array right so
remember the beautiful thing about
Python strings are super easy to deal
with and you can convert them to any
data format you want very quickly I'm
gonna skip that it's a lot of text funny
picture sometimes you get JSON and you
don't like the structure right so we
talked about JSON normalized that will
get you all of the fields if you don't
want all of the fields there's this
really nice package JQ anyone familiar
with this super fast JSON parsing if you
don't know JQ you should learn it
because what you can do is when you're
reading your JSON you can grab all the
other things you want so if you really
only care about two fields and you've
got some horrible JSON that's got like
30 fields some simple statement like
this is gonna get you everything and you
can also use it with the SH utility so
you don't even need to do it from the
command line okay sometimes you have no
idea what's in an enormous JSON file
we've all had the joy of working with
undocumented or inconsistent api's
you're not even sure of the company's
operating but somehow they have some
really nice data you're kind of
interested in maybe you've inherited a
legacy [ __ ] database I think [ __ ] has
been around long enough there is some
confusing legacy stuff out there or
someone just gave you some gnarly JSON
because they didn't know how to deal
with it and they were like I you know
can you just have then walked away um so
the IJ sign module is really nice this
is an iterator JSON parser so you can go
one element at a time this also what it
gives you is a great opportunity to make
data parsing decisions as you
so as you're sort of iterating through
the JSON you can also see what it looks
like it's not gonna be fast right this
is about exploratory data analysis this
is not about processing gigabytes
petabytes of data this is when you're
figuring out what you initially want to
do you're a programmer use iterators
right so the idea is with I Jason you
look at one record at a time one thing I
really like to do is I like to sort of
subclass as I'm reading in the JSON so I
do this thing called recursive check
what that does is it figures out what
things are sort of dictionary like
structures I might want to turn into
special classes so if it's a dictionary
I sort of look at the keys and depending
on the keys I say did I create a class
for those keys already boom I assign it
if I didn't I literally asked myself why
don't you give me a new class name and
write some code and literally I'm gonna
then import that code you just wrote so
you can sort of be coding for your JSON
as you're going and if I have a list I'm
gonna do that for each item in the list
so basically you can build custom
classes or names tuples as you go this
lets you know what you have in your data
right the problem with pandas JSON
normalized is even if I sort of close my
eyes hail-mary I hope it will work I
don't really know how that data was
structured or how many fields I was
supposed to have if I sort of iterate
through it I have a much better idea of
what I'm doing and as I discussed before
this is also again a great time to use
your classes and dynamic class method
assignment to sort of change things as
you're going okay so finally back to the
why again so I wanted to quickly show
you some benefit you get to this right
I've just showed you all of this boring
boring CSV JSON parsing mostly told you
it's taken care of but when it's gnarly
it's really gnarly why might you want to
do this so one really cool thing that
I'm sometimes puzzled we don't see more
of is clustering time series so like I
was saying earlier in my opinion almost
all data we have nowadays is really a
time series right it's very rare to not
have some kind of sequential data about
a user about
experiment about whatever it is that you
are measuring so I would like to see
more clustering and classification of
time series which is why I'm choosing
this it sort of looks like this right I
mean I think clustering of time series
is intuitively just like all sorts of
other clustering the methods are
computationally demanding they're sort
of order N squared formally although
when you look empirically it's more like
10% times order of N squared which does
make a difference right so you're not
really paying that full cost
relatedly classification can be used for
a series or related predictions so it's
not just clustering you can also do
predictions and wouldn't it be cool to
be doing a prediction per user in
addition to doing all your normal sequel
operations so like I was saying this is
very straightforward you can use many
commonly applied clustering algorithms
that you already know okay
I keep thinking you're gonna ask a
question anyway I just want to show you
a few cool examples anyone use the
endomondo running up well you might be
interested to know if you sort of look
at the time series and cluster them
we've sort of got some kind of nordic
cluster going on so Denmark Norway
Sweden all sort of have this morning
evening pattern and then the Baltic
states are all sort of doing their own
thing I didn't select them this way this
is the result of the clustering study
right so if we just sort of look at when
these countries go running we see some
Geographic correlations I have to admit
I made these plots in R so I'm not a
pure Python pythonista this is another
example I'm just really using personal
data I've come across so I used to work
in a nano scale physics lab and what we
would do is we would sort of pull on
molecules and we would measure what the
electrical signal looked like and you
could these are sort of color-coded here
but what you see is if you think about
these as a time series the time series
behave differently for different
molecules and what we do is then we then
add these up into these two dimensional
histograms and you can see that you have
very distinct clusters of time series in
this case with a physical basis reddit
another example so I sort of pulled the
top 25 threads from the main page off of
Reddit for a couple of months and I
looked at sort of what subreddits made
it and how they tended to do and again
saw a great example of why it makes
sense to cluster time series in the
videos over here I don't know if it's
showing up very well but what you can
see is that videos when they make it to
the top they sort of don't last that
long but they get up pretty high right
so the video is pretty funny everyone
clicks on it but I guess everyone has
done seen it so it goes away personal
finance is really kooky because it sort
of comes up right it starts sort of low
and it sort of disappears for a while
and it makes a comeback right this is
the pattern for most of these time
series and then two x-chromosomes never
really does that well tends to last a
little bit longer than a video these
were chosen that random but it just
shows you what you can learn from
grouping time series so quickly how it
works in case you're wondering and
haven't seen it what you basically do is
you don't want to do Euclidean distance
that actually gives you some really crap
results what you do is you sort of
figure out what's the best fit of one
time series to another so that you are
controlling for offsets right offsets
aren't really that meaningful what is
meaningful is how the shape matches the
way you do this is you compute a
distance matrix of each point against
each point you put in some sort of
common-sense band and then you find your
minimum distance path through that
matrix this is a a dynamic programming
problem for those of you who are on the
programming side not terribly difficult
but it can be computationally taxing
however in theory what I was mentioning
before right it's order N squared in
theory in practice even if you don't put
a no lower bound you're only at about
ten percent of N squared and more often
you're out like one person why do we
need the fancy method if you just use
Euclidean distance this red straight
line ends up looking more like ts3 then
like ts2 right so you end up matching a
straight line to assign on the
sinusoidal curve similarly here if you
do Euclidean matching you can sort of
see you get some weird clustering you
really want to stick with that dynamic
time working which is what I was
mentioning and in this example I
actually pulled off a dot n L blog and
this is somebody clustered the time
series oh I'm sorry
clustered the time C
is for bike stands in Washington DC I
don't imagine the author is here today
but it's a pretty cool blog post and it
was just one example of what I was able
to find other people doing right so in
addition to thinking about where things
are or how much they cost or any sort of
sequel like thing you also have this
whole new source of data based on
treating time series like a
characteristic rather than just a time
series of something that doesn't talk
the sequel data just some future
research possibilities that have been
proposed they're sort of text
recognition movie analysis image
recognition I'm just throwing that out
there not too related to the no sequel
but this is my final argument for what
I'm calling no sequel Python right once
we start putting these arrays in and
realizing that a time series is a
characteristic not just a time series
this opens all sorts of novel ways to
think about data and novel questions to
ask so the very short version skipping
the boring JSON parsing pandas is
already well well adapted to the new
sequel world and might not be into super
efficient for these sorts of operations
that's not what it was built for but you
can do anything you can stuff any sort
of custom object you want make your data
format work for you remember that you
are lazy that is just sort of normal but
since you're lazy you want your data to
be in a format that makes the
interesting questions easy to answer
comparative time series go hand-in-hand
with the increasing availability of no
sequel data so I hope more people will
start realizing that these time series
you have about all your internet users
all your game users all your patients
and medical studies you have it's almost
like a whole other dimension of data
that's drastically underused and
similarly just like we saw a talk about
recommender and engines earlier even
data that is not sequential but grouped
has interesting things you can do with
it so that is my talk thank you
questions thanks for your talk just a
practical one is your presentation
available guitar on github but it will
be ok thanks just a quick reminder will
try to post presentation along with the
YouTube videos in two weeks or something
so other questions I I do have one does
the time series recognition works good
when you have mostly small discrete
jumps so it mostly look flat most of the
time jumps up and down so you certainly
if you have more features it works
better but it's amazingly robust and
some other things that are interesting I
didn't get to mention you can compare
time series of unequal length and that
works extraordinarily well you can
compare sort of subsections and find
motifs but definitely the more features
you have as with all data feature rich
data is much more reliably classified
have you used that for also time series
anomaly detection I have not personally
but I think it's a great idea right
that's a whole other set of categories
again I can add to an individual or an
experiment well that's it thank I need
again then then thank you